yeah yeah i got multiple notifications
on linkedin that people were
that that people working in the prime
minister's office were looking at my
profile more than once i got these
notifications and the first time i was
like okay what does that mean then the
second time the third time and it was
clear to me that i had i had
um
i i had said some things that were
that were not so good for their their
public relations team
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the sub stack essayist for noble truths
with rav arora and journalists who i
don't have to put air quotes around it's
quite lovely rav arora welcome back to
the reuben report
hey dave it's good it's good to be on
and it's good to get that formal noble
truce with rav aurora introduction i'm
still working on that branding but i i
like the way you said it for sure i
appreciate it noble truths with rav
it sounds pleasant and lofty and really
the highest compliment that i can give
someone these days the fact that i can
call you a journalist and i didn't have
to do air quotes i mean does it get any
better than that yeah yeah and i i don't
have any formal education so for for
some people that that evokes a lot of
skepticism about who this weirdo writing
in his mom's basement is but i i think
um
i i think for a lot of people it's just
i i just kind of just say what i want to
say and i'm just just straight with the
facts and i don't try to spin it
according to any kind of preconditioned
narrative i'm not working for anybody
i'm just
writing about issues that are important
to me and i don't really identify as
liberal or conservative just kind of
trying to make sense of the world
whatever comes my way and if that means
i'm going to sound a little left on
something or a little right i just just
go for it
well rav i would rather have a weirdo in
his mom's basement than someone that
went to columbia journalism school so
you are good to go most of my audience
probably recognizes you you've been on
the show for multiple uh friday panel
extravaganzas but you do find work as a
journalist you are up in canada and the
reason i wanted to do this condensed
interview with you today and we're just
sort of shooting this on the fly is
because you've gotten into some hot
water with your prime minister up there
in canada justin trudeau who in my
estimation is the most authoritarian
i would say world leader from a western
nation
and you've been writing a bit about him
and what's going on in canada and now
the government is looking into you
you scary person in your mom's basement
yeah yeah i i don't know why i'm so
threatening i mean i don't know my my
mom has been funny about this and i
cannot i can talk about that in a second
but
but um yeah i i wrote an op-ed in the
new york post calling trudeau basically
a
horrible authoritarian leader who's
violated basic human rights civil
liberties and constitutional
um rights specifically with respect to
the vaccine mandates and i i just talked
about how
my family were immigrants from india and
we came to canada in search for more
freedom whether it's financial social uh
political vocational we just wanted more
opportunities and that was kind of the
idea that my that my mom and my dad had
is to give us more freedoms right
give their kids more freedom so they can
pursue what they want to pursue
and here we are during the covet
pandemic and
you know yes there are many issues
surrounding uh keeping people safe
keeping vulnerable people safe and there
are various uh restrictions that perhaps
make sense
but when it came to just my freedom it
was completely restricted i couldn't go
to the gym for the longest time for for
several months couldn't go out to a
restaurant and dine in and i couldn't i
couldn't even travel by air i couldn't
even fly or or go on a train anywhere in
the country let alone leave the country
for
several months due to
the uh travel vaccine mandates that
outright discriminated outright banned
the unvaccinated from traveling anywhere
other than if you want to go in your car
but but even even that you couldn't
cross the u.s canada border and i i
missed out on a lot of um opportunities
like in december for example i was
talking to ben shapiro's team um i've
been on the show a couple times and we
were thinking about doing something in
florida actually at the time in person
and i just couldn't go because i was
banned i was deemed
um as a second-class citizen who was not
able to travel
and so in this article that i wrote i
just made that point of
in many ways
my freedoms would have been more secured
in india the country that i came from
than here even though we came here for
more freedoms and that that to me is
just
a total a total travesty and really
makes us reevaluate what the supposedly
free liberal democracy here
in in canada where our freedoms are
completely restricted
so you write the piece in the new york
post and of course nothing you're saying
is coming as a surprise to my audience
because obviously we've covered a lot of
what's going on with trudeau in canada
and the trucker convoy and freezing of
bank accounts and and all of that stuff
so i think everyone watching this is is
on board they hear what you're saying
but then how did this thing level up uh
you suddenly found uh some government
people were doing a little digging on
you
yeah yeah i got multiple notifications
on linkedin that people were
that that people working in the prime
minister's office were looking at my
profile more than once i got these
notifications and the first time i was
like okay what does that mean then the
second time the third time and it was
clear to me that i had i had
um
i i had said some things that were
that were not so good for their their
public relations team and and and i
don't know who it was that looked at me
whether it was just some
you know 27 year old intern at the
public relations office or or whether it
was somebody higher up um
a lot of people think it's somebody
perhaps higher up who
um for them like this is really bad
press right and that's obviously not my
goal my goal is not to just [ __ ] on
trudeau you know my goal is to just
say what i honestly want to say and talk
about some of the
disturbing authoritarian trends in this
country and it just
it seemed to have uh
rung an alarm for them and they wanted
to
look into me and i don't know what the
implications of that is other than i'm
on the prime minister's radar and i
should probably put that on my twitter
bio
it should be on your twitter bio for as
long as you're allowed to be on twitter
i know a little something about how
tenuous that can be but can you just
talk like joking aside for a second you
just talk about the chilling effect of
that i mean look you're you're outspoken
publicly you're a young person trying to
make your bones make your career um you
are publicly unbacked so you could not
leave the country uh you're you're
critical of the government and now you
have government agents in essence uh
looking closely at your work i mean you
know you're in your mom's basement as
you said it's not it's not the most fun
thing in the world
yeah yeah i know i
some people have mentioned to me that i
should take this a bit more seriously
than i am and i think that's just just
my personality is like i i i don't take
these things super super seriously and
lose sleep over them i mean if if
trudeau is losing sleep over me you know
that's fine enough i don't want to lose
sleep over making trudeau lose sleep but
but no no
in all seriousness it is
it is very chilling that one article can
have that kind of effect especially
given that i don't really have
like a massive platform yet i'm still
growing i'm still
a young person and
i mean i mean even just on twitter too
with that article
that i posted there were so many
journalists government-funded
journalists by the way working for the
cbc
working for
global news the toronto star
that were uh pointing out that this
op-ed is total balderdash and he should
just get vaccinated and he's just
whining about his freedoms and and a lot
of people by the way weirdly enough were
saying oh he should just go back to
india why is he even here like people
like that were saying and it's like whoa
whoa whoa whoa why did we just go like
trump suddenly like why like i thought
this was a rhetoric that you know was
associated with trump
and and then that was one of the points
of that essay and a couple of other
essays that i've written before too
it's like the direction we went in in
the name of
safety diversity inclusivity
it's it's exactly what we feared would
be
of the other side like trudeau
genuinely has become
this monstrous discriminatory
authoritarian leader that we all feared
trump would be and i'm no trump defender
i'm not going to
you know defend him or openly support
him or just any of that but what trudeau
is displaying is true
authoritarianism it's true
stripping people away from their
constitutional rights and their civil
liberties
and it's it's you know when you're a
young journalist you know i'm definitely
um not you know part of the the
conventional narrative because i'm i'm
not writing for the cbc i'm not writing
for any of these traditional outlets i'm
just an independent writer and it seems
to me there's there's a weird shortage
of that here in canada like otherwise
it's mysterious why i've risen whereas
other
journalists haven't it's like there
aren't enough independent journalists
who are willing to say what i'm willing
to say because they rather get their
journalism degree and work for the cbc
and get paid a certain salary and spew
out the same political narrative over
and over again but for me it's like that
i don't want to be anything close to
that i want to be my own independent
voice and raise these these concerns
about my country
yeah i mean you bring up a couple
interesting interesting things i mean
first this idea that that trudeau in
essence has become what they purported
trump to be trump turned out not to
really be those things for all his
faults and now you've got trudeau who's
actually doing many of those things and
you exercising that state power but to
your latter point about these
journalists that go work for the cbc and
everything else you guys have a major
problem right now in canada that we
don't necessarily have here yet or at
least so obviously which is that the
government not only does fund a huge
amount of your journalism overtly here
they do it more subtly
but now independent journalists like you
and ezra levant over at the rebel and a
bunch of other people that are trying to
do some interesting things in canada are
going to be held to sort of untenable
standards when it comes to your work
right
yeah
yeah yeah exactly it's the
there's a very small minority of
journalists who are doing what what me
and ezra and
i'm trying to think who else i would put
in that category i mean rex rex murphy
writes for the national post so he he
writes for
um an established outlet that's
conservative leaning and he's been on
jordan's podcast a bunch to talk about
canadian politics but i i think the
incentives are so stacked like if you're
if you're a young journalist right my
age or a bit older and you're
conservative leaning or libertarian
leaning
and you're really dissatisfied with what
the government is doing right now it's
like
why would you ever want to do this like
why would you ever want to get into this
career path where
the the odds are so stacked against you
that you you you know if you want to
have a well-paying job if you want to
put food on the table for your family
you you have to apply to the cbc the
toronto star and you have to continually
perpetuate and regurgitate these same
narratives otherwise you're not going to
be
making a lot of money i mean
even with like
uh even with local outlets here like i
live in the small city called chilliwack
about an hour away from vancouver
and the editor of the child progress
he's openly called me like an alt-right
conspiracy theorist a right-winger
somebody who's uh who's covering for
white people like he's openly blocked me
on all platforms he's called me outright
and the horrible names and it's like
like our local newspaper which is
thankfully dying and it's not doing that
well even there there's a very
established a deep established narrative
even though we live in a fairly
conservative area actually but even the
local media outlets let alone the
national the federal the provincial
level outlets they've also
established this given narrative and so
you you have a lot of people who might
be interested in becoming journalists
but they just see that that this is not
going to be financially sustainable so
then they become professors they become
accountants or lawyers or doctors or
whatever that's kind of where it's at
but so it's it's very rare for people
like me who are young who have kind of
taken this risk and maybe because i'm
young i'm more able to take a bit of
that risk because i have certain
freedoms you know living with my parents
still and doing these kind of things
where i can take these big risks and
speak out for for what i want to say
whereas whereas other people just
financially
given the media ecosystem just aren't
able to
how much longer do you think the
situation in canada is sustainable i
mean look you've got people like jordan
peterson who are outspoken critics of
the government and i think jordan is at
least considering leaving canada all
together gad sad who of course professor
concordia one of my best friends you
know he is often talking about leaving
canada uh viva fry another big actual
journalist lawyer he just left he moved
to florida this week i mean the brain
drain on a society like that can't last
forever no no it's
again i've already talked about
journalism but this same with academia
you know you you go like even my local
university you know i've already
mentioned my local newspaper they hate
me the local university
there's also professors there um who uh
there was one a think tank that i wanted
to be part of that was about having
young people talk about real political
issues particularly about race and i
wanted to get into this and the
professor openly said to me like no
you're not welcome like we don't want
any of your views here you know like the
dominant narrative within universities
it's so centralized it's so
narrow-minded that
people who even
are outside of the norm they're
immediately excluded and they're
immediately marginalized so there's this
big intellectual dominant force that's
very left-leaning here in canada across
universities and and i'm not going to
say like all universities or everybody's
like that there are there are wonderful
professors that i work with although
more about like religion or psychology
or other things that aren't as
politically affected you might say but
for for for journalists who are coming
up right now and for people in academia
in the humanities and
the liberal arts it's like there's an
increasing
ideological monoculture where you have
to abide by these certain
religious precepts with regards to
gender with regards to race with regards
to inequality with regards to
vaccination status and if you don't toe
that line then you're immediately an
outsider and it's it's it's making
people like myself think about
potentially moving too i don't know what
will happen but i think i'll definitely
want to move here from
at some point in the future i don't know
if you've heard but the sun is always
shining here in the free state of
florida
hey i would consider it i would
genuinely consider that
all right well we'll take this offline
all right well i wanted to do this
quickly with you just so that people
could hear about this because you are
fighting the good fight up there i
didn't know you were doing it from your
mom's basement now it seems doubly cool
what you're doing so keep fighting and
uh we'll link to your sub stack down
below so people can yeah of course hey
it's a nice basement here it's a nice
basement it's not that you got a window
in the basement i mean that's pretty
good like she's just throwing fish heads
down there once a week by the way i'll
just quickly say too like my mom has
been very fearful and discouraging me
from ever writing anything bad about
trudeau she's been like rav we do we
need do we need body guards outside like
you have little siblings rap who go to
school like don't ruin their reputation
by being this like supposed scary right
winger she's like maybe we have to move
places or change addresses like don't
write anything bad about trudeau in her
very indian mom kind of way i'm like i'm
like mom i'm gonna move out and she's
like fine do it and i'll like i'll move
with dave rubin and look after his his
uh his kids in august maybe
the only thing is we don't have
basements in florida because of the
storms the flooding so let me see what i
can do i'll get back to you on that yeah
yeah yeah you got to expose some racial
diversity they need to see some brown
they need to see some brown faces
indeed indeed all right wrap keep up the
good work man all right thanks if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell